Said this before and I'll say it again.
When someone is working in a healthcare setting,
you are sacrificing your life years
to save other people's lives,
to extend their life.
You're shortening your own life.
Being a doctor
is up there with one of the most stressful jobs
you can have.
All of these factors
contribute to making a ridiculously
difficult job to deal with.
And every year,
or actually every few months,
I actually even asked myself,
is it time I walk away?
Is it time I quit? Wow.
And I've constantly said that to myself.
And during the pandemic,
those kind of 23 years,
I said that myself more times than ever.
Like, Do I need to hang up my boots here? Am I done?
It's really getting to me now.
I'm close to burnout.
What's getting to you?
I think it's everything.
It's the stress of the job,
not being able to have a work life balance,
not seeing my family enough.
During the pandemic,
I think it accentuated
my fears and the worries I had about the job
and how it impacted my life.
I didn't want to go into work
and then come home to my parents
and potentially myself have COVID
and then go to my parents house.
So, you know,
I didn't want to be at home a lot of the time
and then not seeing my parents.
I'm a lonely child,
so not seeing my parents
was something I wasn't comfortable. With.
So it was that
just the sleeplessness,
the stress of the job,
but also career progression.
You need to progress in your careers.
That involves doing exams,
you know, doing interviews,
constantly appraising yourself,
revalidating yourself.
That means publishing papers,
going to conferences,
going to courses.
And so this is all called
CPD continues
professional development.
So aside from your job,
dealing with people's lives
and disease
and sickness and health,
you need to improve yourself.
And going on conferences and courses
are bloody expensive.
Few years back,
one of the exams I had to sit for
my surgical exams,
they cost me a couple of grand
just to sit the exams. Oh, my gosh.
I'm going to a conference in a couple of months
time to go to the conference and publish my
research that I'm presenting.
All of that is around a grand.
And sometimes
when you're publishing a piece of research
into a journal,
some of the papers require you to pay a fee.
So there's constant,
you know, on top of that,
the GMC license
to maintain my license,
a few hundred quid.
And the British Medical Association
to pay for that.
It's also a few hundred pounds
to maintain my post
nominals, MRCS,
you know, member of the Royal College of Surgeons.
I need to pay a few hundred pounds
to the Royal College of surgeons
to maintain that.
So I am leaking money
out of every orifice
just to maintain my profession.
And On top of that,
you need to progress.
So one thing is dealing with patients
and the other thing is career progression.
It's a money game.